there was a video this is going to seem
unconnected but it's not
there was a video that was going around
the internet over the past few days
of a cool old plane making an emergency
landing
in the water along a beach in florida so
so the plane is making its landing and
and it so it's really actually pretty
impressive emergency landing doesn't
doesn't take anybody out and you see the
the plane just floating now a little bit
off
shore some guys are filming this from
the beach
and already you think wow this is very
impressive video but the most impressive
part comes
when a bunch of dudes start running into
the water
diving into the water and swimming out
to the plane
why are they doing that because they
want to make sure that nobody in the
plane needs help
that nobody's drowning that nobody has
maybe been knocked unconscious
they're running toward the danger using
their will and their intellect
to do the right thing taking the
situation
in some degree into their own hands and
behaving in a moral manner as they do it
we can do that i know that we we live in
a country now
that is just filled with the neurotic
and selfish fear of death
where if forget about a plane landing
and you're gonna go run toward the
danger
now if your grandma coughs
you run in the other direction you say
good death take her take her i've gotta
i gotta get out of here i'm not gonna
see
my relatives my loved ones for years at
a time now
because i'm so afraid of getting the
sniffles
right we are a cowardly and selfish
country in many ways
we're quickly becoming that because of
radicals who are trying to upend our our
system of
society but we don't have to be we can
be the other kind of society
that just doesn't care about our
our own self of satisfaction all the
time
that doesn't only care about our
self-preservation actually runs toward
the danger
to do the right thing stop
wait wait okay i'm glad i've got your
attention
i need you to like and subscribe you got
to smash the button do whatever
crazy verb you got to do you got to do
it because
youtube sometimes doesn't love us
okay and they don't necessarily want to
pump our videos up to the top of your
feed so if you don't want to miss a
video
make sure you like and subscribe right
[Music]
now
[Music]
you